[Musique]
j'ai bu comme mes frères et soeurs
l'amour du patrimoine dans le lait de
notre mère nous avons hérité de ce
château qui appartient la famille depuis
quatorze 167
[Musique]
un château qui selui c'est un château
qui s'est toujours mais que vous avez
toujours fait énormément de choses
mes parents quand ils ont décidé
d'ouvrir le château publicis était pour
partager la beauté du château le
témoignage de ce qu apporte l château
toutes les expositions que vous avez
organisé les amis justement qui viennent
le salon de curiosité les concerts que
ma tante avait créé c'est un endroit qui
réalise c'est une histoire humaine mais
historique passionnante dont nous avons
plein de traces y a pas que le bâtiment
ya pas que les jardins il ya aussi cette
histoire tous ces personnages compte
livre est né et c'est assez
impressionnant de se retrouver nous
maintenant à le carré là la tête de ça
et tu peux te dire qu'on suit tous ces
élus ce personnage et tout ce travail
qui a été fait c'est un endroit qui a
toujours été liée à l'histoire de france
à cause du rôle de nos ancêtres
ils ont les uns et les autres marqué
leur temps par la foule et je trouve ça
formidable
tarin kowt et vertigineux c'est sûr mais
c'est une très belle aventure on a envie
de continuer à partager cet endroit et
une envie c'est un devoir par amour pour
le lieu mais par à montlouis de
témoignages de l'histoire ça se gère pas
comme une entreprise ça résume maison
familiale et 7 pas les mêmes potentiel
qu'une entreprise se plus comme une
aventure c'est pas du business
le business entre guillemets rentre là
pour nous aider à maintenir en état un
endroit pareil
aujourd'hui une famille moderne ne vit
pas seul ici les enfants participent
beaucoup ça leur crée des souvenirs
formidables ils s'intéressent du coup au
lieu à ce qui s'y passe six qui
construit leur amour pour le lait
[Musique]